[Musik]
Amerika gibt Gas
als der ukraine-krieg losging schoss die
Nachfrage nach unserem Gas durch die
Decke
Putins Überfall auf die Ukraine bedeutet
eine Zeitenwende auch für den
Energiesektor Europas erdgasemanzipation
im Eiltempo auch die Nachfrage aus
Deutschland lässt in den USA die
kassenklingeln
Goldgräberstimmung an der Golfküste LNG
for Germany
Germany deutschland hat in kürzester
Zeit drei Terminals gebaut Sie schon
jetzt Flüssiggas empfangen und bald
werden es fünf vielleicht sechs sein
solche eine rasante Entwicklung ist
beispiellos
wo kommt der Rohstoff her der unsere
Wohnzimmer warm hält wie empfinden die
Menschen vor Ort den Boom
was tut die Industrie um die Förderung
und Verflüssigung umweltschonender zu
gestalten
wir suchen Antworten und sind auch euren
Fragen nachgegangen seltene Einblicke in
eine von manchen schon tot geglaubte
Industrie deren Zukunft jetzt
schillernder denn je erscheint
Energie steht für Innovation und
Widerstandsfähigkeit
die Welt hat ein Energieproblem die
Nachfrage vieler Länder nach us-gas
steigt
der Boom für einige ein Riesengeschäft
für andere eine Katastrophe für Umwelt
und Gesundheit
[Musik]
wir sind unterwegs in Corpus Christi
Texas die 300.000 Einwohner Stadt ist
einer der Hotspots der amerikanischen
Energieindustrie ein halbes Jahr lang
haben wir bei sämtlichen Unternehmen
Drehgenehmigungen angefragt ohne jeden
Erfolg dann endlich sagt uns eine Firma
zu Genia einer der größten Gas
Verflüssiger der Welt lässt uns seine
Anlagen Filmen wir werden von Teamleiter
Mars ins empfangen gerade als der
ankommen liegt ein Schiff Richtung
Europa ab beladen mit rund 170.000
Kubikmetern Flüssigkeit
[Musik]
diese für flüssigungsanlage hier in
Corpus Christi ist einer unserer Hubs
von denen aus wie das Ganze exportieren
dort hinten sehen Sie die großen
ladearmen mit ihnen befüllen wir die
Tanks auf den Schiffen
das Erdgas in sogenannten Zügen bringt
es in flüssige komprimierte Form um
möglichst viele auf die Schiffe zu
bekommen etwa alle zwei Tage legt ein
Schiff dieser Größe hier vom Hafen ab
viel mehr wollen sie uns nicht zeigen
die Skepsis gegenüber Medien ist groß
das lässt man uns auch spüren wir dürfen
die Anlagen nur aus weiter Ferne drehen
mehr ist absolut tabu offiziell wegen
Sicherheitsbedenken schließlich drehen
wir in einer hochentzündlichen Umgebung
der eigentliche Grund aber scheint für
uns vor allem Angst vor Imageschaden zu
sein unter anderem das Fracking und die
giftigen Gase bedrohen Natur und Mensch
die fossile Industrie ist stark
umstritten und ein schlechtes Image ist
schlecht fürs Geschäft
dabei könnte es kaum besser laufen das
Terminal eines der ertragreichsten
Projekte für chines gerade mal fünf
Jahre alt stößt es seit Beginn des
russischen angriffskriegs gegen die
Ukraine an seine Belastungsgrenze unter
anderem die Nachfrage aus Deutschland
ist im letzten Jahr explodiert auch
deshalb hat China beschlossen den
ohnehin schon R iesigen Standort weiter
auszubauen
was Sie hier sehen können sind die Züge
eins bis drei das sind die Originalzüge
die wir damals gebaut haben und dann
schauen Sie hier rüber da können Sie
sehen was wir gerade neu bauen nämlich
zusätzliche sieben Züge sie werden
jeweils 1,5 Millionen Tonnen pro Jahr
fördern
gesteuert wird das Mammutprojekt von
Houston aus dem Management Mekka der
amerikanischen Öl- und Gasindustrie hier
haben zahlreiche energiegiganten ihren
Hauptsitz so auch Schiern
[Musik]
wir sind verabredet mit dem
Vertriebsvorstand der Firma Anatol
Felgen im Gespräch bestätigt er dass die
Branche die er vertritt vom Krieg gegen
die Ukraine profitiert 70% des
verflüssigten Gases lieferte Shinya im
letzten Jahr an Europa die nun
geschlossene Neuverträge auch mit
Deutschland haben eine deutlich höhere
Laufzeit als früher im Schnitt sind es
17 Jahre
vor dem Hintergrund des extremen Marktes
der durch die Pipeline und
lieferkonflikte in Europa zusätzlich
unter Druck geriet vor diesem
Hintergrund wurde es attraktiver
Verpflichtungen mit langer Laufzeit
einzugehen für uns bedeutet das wir
können weiter wachsen
weiter wachsen können damit auch
zahlreiche Zulieferbetriebe ad Pössl hat
sein ganzes Leben in Corpus Christi
verbracht der 67-Jährige arbeitet für
eine Firma die sich auf Schläuche
spezialisiert hat und Genia beliefert er
profitiert vom Erfolg der Gasunternehmen
Umwelt und gesundheitsbedenken wischt er
schnell weg und erklärt uns dass es doch
gerade die Gasindustrie sei die hier
Arbeitsplätze schaffe und guten Lohn
bringen und das Geschäft gut bestätigt
im ersten Quartal dieses Jahres stiegen
die Verkaufszahlen seiner Firma um 20%
in seinen Augen ein Segen für die ganze
Region
für unsere Gemeinde es sorgt für eine
Menge Jobs wir haben auch gerade erst
neue Verkäufer eingestellt und Wachsen
genauso wie andere Läden in der Gegend
Restaurants eröffnen neue Firmen Leute
kaufen Autos
wirtschaftlich geht es also überall
bergauf die Leute finden Arbeit mit der
sie ihre Familien versorgen können
zweimal pro Woche liefert Haus auf South
Texas Schläuche an Genia der
Energieriese betreibt das älteste und
größte flüssiggasterminal der USA und
ist einer ihrer wichtigsten Kunden vom
Auto aus können wir dann wenigstens ein
paar naheblicke auf die Anlage erhaschen
dabei bleibt es aber auch
wir konfrontieren einer tollen Felgen
mit unseren Eindrücken und den Umwelt
Bedenken vor allem zu methan-ausstoß der
massiv zur Erderwärmung beiträgt die
Industrie hat das lange billig in den
Kauf genommen eine überzeugende Lösung
scheint nicht in Sicht
wir beginnen nun damit Equipment und
Technologie einzusetzen und zu fördern
um in Echtzeit präzise Angaben über
Methan Lecks zusammen diese
Informationen werden wir dann benutzen
um den Emissionsausstoß an den
verschiedenen Stellen im Prozess zu
verringern wir stehen da aber noch in
den Kinderschuhen und das wird an
unserer Branche auch zu Recht kritisiert
wir sind aber zuversichtlich dass wir da
in den kommenden Jahren große
Fortschritte machen werden
wir drehen bei der Firma die schignier
für solche methanmessungen beauftragt
hat
Brandon Smith hat früher bei der NASA
gearbeitet dort entwickelte er einen
Sensor der auf maßmissionen zum Einsatz
kommt nun ist er selbstständig und nutzt
seine Erfindung anderweitig
es ist der leichteste und präziseste
Sensor der Teile pro Milliarde in der
Luft messen kann wir befestigen ihn an
einer Drohne so dass wir eine Gaswolke
in allen drei Dimensionen erfassen
können
wir können unsere Sensoren also überall
hinfliegen über eine Förderplattform
eine Biogas oder LNG-Anlage und Methan
Emissionen lokalisieren und
quantifizieren
mit diesen Daten können die Kunden wie
schenieur dann die lex gezielt schließen
das ist gut für die Umwelt und den
Firmenumsatz dass die Öl- und
Gasindustrie grüner werden wolle sei
keine Gewissensentscheidung meint
Bränden den großen Unternehmen könne man
nur mit einem Hebeldruck machen
nur eine Sprache und das ist Dollar
jetzt kommen aber die Finanzaufsicht und
die EU und sagen wir werden jetzt
regulieren in welcher Form ihr darüber
berichtet wie grün ihr seid
und da kommen wir ins Spiel wir können
die präzisen Daten liefern die die
Firmen für eben solche Berichte
benötigen und damit den Wandel antreiben
Sieg Ops wertet die gemessenen Daten
auch selbst aus bevor das Ergebnis dann
an den Kunden geschickt wird
die Daten werden in einer Art
cloud-visualisiert am Ende kann man dann
ein dreidimensionales Objekt von allen
Winkeln betrachten und das methangass
sichtbar machen wir haben für die
Auswertung ein spezielles Team das
schaut sich auch die Strömungsrichtung
an und kann so lokalisieren wo das
Methan kommt
Sonnenaufgang über Cameron parish
Louisiana
kaum ein Ort in Amerika hat eine
vergleichbare Biodiversität
unendliche maßlandschaften Gesicht der
Golfküste so war es früher vielerorts
[Musik]
Bilder die vergessen lassen das hier das
Epizentrum der amerikanischen Öl und
Gasindustrie ist
einer der das nicht ausblenden kann ist
John leer vor 25 Jahren hat er sein
Grundstück gekauft lange bevor LNG
überhaupt Thema war der 64-Jährige hat
hier seine drei Kinder großgezogen nun
kommen regelmäßig auch die Enkel zu
Besuch ein Ort der für John idylle pur
verkörperte
bis wenige Kilometer entfernt eine
LNG-Anlage gebaut wurde bald soll sogar
noch eine zweite entstehen direkt
nebenan
der gesamte Lebensraum hier wird
verschwinden aufgeschüttet mit Zement
und Steinen
das alles wird verschwinden
John zeigt uns die Bebauungspläne als
Ingenieur hat er selbst jahrzehntelang
in der Öl- und Gasindustrie gearbeitet
nun kämpft er gegen sie an als Insider
kennt er die Branche gut er hat kaum
Hoffnung die Expansionspläne nebenan
stoppen zu können weltweit arbeiteten
Regierungen an Plänen die Förderung von
fossilen Energien schrittweise
herunterzuschrauben die USA hingegen
erzählt uns John geben der Industrie
weiterhin einen Freifahrtschein zum
Gelddrucken
wir haben keinen Plan außer diesen
Unternehmen möglichst schnell hohe
Profite einzutreiben
jeder Amerikaner der Energie verbraucht
sorg dafür dass ein Teil seines Gehalts
jeden Monat in die Taschen der Öl- und
gasfirmen fließt
und die wollen so viel Geld wie möglich
so schnell wie möglich machen
dass die Industrie auch Geld in die
öffentlichen kassenspüle sei
Augenwischerei mein John von den
Rekordumsätzen Lande kaum etwas bei den
Menschen die akute energienot in Europa
verstehe er Gas und Öl könnten aber
nicht die Antwort darauf sein zumal die
Ressourcen endlich sein und wir sie für
jene Bereiche aufsparen sollten in denen
es keine Alternativen gäbe
[Musik]
wir sollten fossile Brennstoffe nur noch
dort einsetzen wo es nicht anders geht
ein Flugzeug kann nicht mit Windenergie
fliegen für diese Dinge gibt es bisher
keine Alternative als fossile
Brennstoffe
in anderen Bereichen müssen wir
unbedingt Umsteuern um die begrenzten
fossilen Ressourcen die
Kohlenwasserstoffe aufzusparen für die
Produkte für die wir sie auch künftig
dringend brauchen
unser nächster Stopp in betona ist ein
besonderer denn diesmal haben wir Fragen
unserer ZDF YouTube-Community im Gepäck
die wir direkt und unverändert unserem
Protagonisten Stellen Jason French hat
jahrelang im Öl und Gasgeschäft
gearbeitet unter anderem für schenier
jetzt baut er das LNG Center auf
excellent auf an dem Studierende auf
verschiedene Jobs in der Gas-
möchte wissen wie groß der
Preisunterschied zwischen russischem Gas
via Pipelines und amerikanischem Gas wie
er Schiff ist außerdem wird der Gaspreis
auf lange Sicht wieder fallen
den genauen Preisunterschied kann ich
zwar nicht beziffern man kann aber schon
sagen dass es sehr teuer ist Gas auf
-162°c zu kühlen ist auf Schiffe zu
verladen und über den Ozean zu
transportieren es ist immer günstiger
Erdgas per Pipeline zu transportieren es
ist ein Vorteil den Russland strukturell
immer haben wird falls es diesen nutzen
will falls deutschland und andere
EU-Staaten beschließen sollten doch
wieder Gas von Russland zu beziehen
tatsache ist aber auch das us-gas und
Gas aus anderen Teilen der Welt eine
stabile und sichere Energiequelle sind
und ich denke dass dieser Aspekt in der
EU wichtiger wird Angesicht sehen
Versionen der Ukraine kann ich Ihnen den
genauen Preisunterschied nicht sagen
weil sich die Märkte ständig ändern aber
er ist beträchtlisch
die nächste Frage kommt von unserem
Nutzer t9r ST nnn er schreibt er seinen
Familienvater mit zwei Kindern und
heizte sein Haus mit Flüssigkeit seine
monatlichen Kosten hätten sich
verdoppelt und er fragt sich ob die
Preise bald wieder auf Vorkriegsniveau
kommen
ich glaube es ist unrealistisch dass das
in naher Zukunft passiert Deutschland
und der EU sind insgesamt seit Beginn
des ukraine-konflikts so viele
Gasquellen weggebrochen und die
Regierungen versuchen immer unabhängiger
von Russland zu werden
also selbst wenn der Krieg morgen enden
würde wird der Kurs zu mehr
Unabhängigkeit von russischen Gas
bleiben also ich glaube dass wir so
schnell nicht wieder auf die Preise von
vor dem Krieg kommen werden
unsere letzte community-frage kommt von
Egon Redman 6058 er möchte wissen warum
er nicht einfach eine Pipeline von den
USA noch Europa baut wäre das nicht
wirtschaftlicher als Flüssiggas per
Schiff zu transportieren
eine Pipeline durch den Atlantischen
Ozean zu legen wäre keine Machbare oder
kostengünstige Lösung gerade auch wenn
man den Wartungsbedarf bedenkt stellen
Sie sich mal vor sie müssen einen Leck
irgendwo tief im Meer finden und
reparieren das ist nicht praktikabel der
einzige Weg er denn je über einen Ozean
zu transportieren ist verschiff
[Musik]
wir fahren weiter ins dreieinhalb
Stunden entfernte Porta Texas gut 56.000
Menschen leben hier viele fliehen trotz
des gasbuchs
warum das so ist fragen wir Ron Burton
verwaltungsschef der Stadt früher
erzählt er uns stand der Ort für
Wachstum Wohlstand geschäftiges Treiben
heute erinnert das Zentrum an eine
apokalyptische netflix-kulisse ganze
Straßenzüge verweist
die Öl- und Gas Giganten seien Segen und
Fluch zugleich erzählt er sie bräuchten
Geld machten die Gegend aber auch
lebensfeindlich die Krebsrate in porta
liegt 11% über dem texanischen
Durchschnitt auch deshalb sind in den
letzten Jahren immer mehr Menschen
weggezogen
Ron weiß aber auch dass die riesigen
Investitionen auch einen Großteil der
städtischen Rechnungen zahlen wer die
mächtige Industrie von ihr vertreiben
wolle Kämpfer auf verlorenem Posten es
gehe hier schließlich um wohl und wer
des gesamten Marktes
jede Entscheidung die wir hier treffen
hat globale und nationale Auswirkungen
was die Öl als auch die Gase Industrie
anbetrifft es geht um die
Energieunabhängigkeit der Vereinigten
Staaten von Amerika wir haben hier ein
Sprichwort das besagt wenn Port Affe
niesen muss bekommt die Wall Street eine
Erkältung
Ron nimmt uns mit auf eine Bootsfahrt
entlang des küstenkanals
auch hier ist das Wachstum der Industrie
deutlich zu sehen im Januar gelang es
den USA mit dem weltweit größten
gasexporteur Katar aufzuschließen doch
der Boom hat einen Preis mit diesem
Widerspruch ist der Stadtverwalter
regelmäßig konfrontiert
für uns ist es ein Balanceakt auf der
einen Seite müssen wir das
Wirtschaftswachstum weiter ankurbeln auf
der anderen Seite müssen wir uns um die
gesundheitsbedenken der Leute kümmern
wir können das hinbekommen aber ich bin
davon überzeugt ohne eine starke
Wirtschaft die die Lebensbedingungen
verbessert geht es nicht
den Ukraine Krieg bekommen auch die
Menschen und die Natur an der Golfküste
zu spüren auf der einen Seite Milliarden
Investitionen Arbeitsplätze Rekord
umsetze auf der anderen verpestete Luft
zerstörte Natur ausgestorbene Städte
kurzfristig scheint es kaum Alternativen
zu geben auf die lange Strecke aber kann
auch LNG aus den USA nicht die Antwort
auf Europas Energiebedarf sein und so
ist jetzt vor allem die Politik
gefordert sie muss Rahmenbedingungen
schaffen um unseren akuten Energiehunger
zu stillen und dabei die Umweltbelastung
so gering wie möglich zu halten
gleichzeitig wird die große Frage immer
dringender wie können wir uns mittel und
langfristig unabhängiger machen von
fossilen Brennstoffen